let's talk about what's happening with
Harvey Weinstein I know you posted on
Facebook already but you haven't kind of
spoken yet publicly about what's going
on I think that this is yeah I'm always
trying to look for the rainbow in the
cloud the whatever is the silver lining
and this is what I do know for sure when
something this major happens when you
have the fallout 50 women coming forward
that it's a watershed moment and what I
do believe is actually happening is that
first of all it's triggering a lot of
unreleased pain repressed anger guilt
and suffering that a lot of women have
had I happen to be on set with several
actresses the other day and we were
filming some things and they were like
they were hadn't slept over a period of
two or three days and I was like what is
that and I said oh you guys are
suffering from PTSD and we never be
talking about it out loud - everybody
has a story
everybody has a story and so I think
this is a watershed moment and if we
make this just about Harvey Weinstein
then we will have lost this moment I
think this is a moment where no matter
what business you work in there have
been women who not only had the disease
to please that's a part of it but who
felt that in order to keep my job in
order to keep my position in order to
keep moving forward I've got a smile
I've got to look the other way I got to
pretend he didn't say that I got to
pretend he didn't touch me I think those
days are about to be over and if it
happens to you back in the day you would
say I'm sometimes you're not even aware
what he just said was it really
inappropriate I know you've had a couple
moment where you think what did he just
yes I remember Gail had a moment when
she came and said to me what somebody
say to me no inappropriate I was like oh
my god you can see over that but no and
all I said was what did you say and then
they repeated it yes typing with my
twenty-something yeah if you pretend
it's okay but you didn't know it isn't
you're right Jeff it absolutely
absolutely but a lot of women have been
silent and I know I think it's gonna be
being a victim of child sexual abuse
that when you feel like you cannot be
heard and then other people start
speaking out it
makes you feel like oh now I can speak
out to you've been speaking about it for
four years four years